[Musique]
voilà ma chambre et à l'accueillir de
ses pompes
on m'avait demandé de préparer vos rides
la voilà pourquoi une bride of f parce
que la peau rides est un plat qui est à
la portée de toutes les bourses et
surtout que l'on peut faire dans toute
la france car il se compose de poissons
blancs et de poisson bleu et on en
trouve deux parties et c'est moins cher
que ça c'est moins cher qu'en passant de
roche le poisson de roche est
inaccessible aux bourses moyennes et
c'est la raison pour laquelle je vous
prépare une bruine aujourd'hui alors là
vous allez alors je vous devenu un loup
un merlan une galinette à ce qu'avait
parise a fait le rouget grondin une race
blanche un saint pierre une vivre et un
ciné et bien entendu le poisson de base
qui a droit
combien de la personne grandiront 500
grammes vous 500 g de moules frites pour
réussir de bonnes bruit qu'il faut de
l'huile d'olive des joignons de light
des pommes de terre du fenouil du thym
et du persil sel et poivre bien entendu
alors maintenant il vous reste à vous
exécutez et bien sûr le faire
immédiatement devant vous alors en quoi
consiste la première opération est bien
c'est de préparer mon poisson pour le
mettre là bas dans la variété la
commission marché nous avons beaucoup de
petits poissons jouent sur le fort et
que les ménagères donneront certainement
pas je le couple était ridicule pour le
montrer comment faire comment on fait un
fond de bruits non parce que on concède
dans les tec qu'il y a le plus de goût
de profs et avions beaucoup de goût on
les membranes et ses très bons les
tenanciers ça permet de faire un très
bon club
pauvres bêtes une soupe de tête nous
allons faire presque et vous verrez que
c'est délicieux
parce que nous allons la manger et vous
allez vous régaler elle était visant
voilà elle n'est plus
voilà alors j'imagine maintenant que le
poisson est prêts font que vous allez
passer au fond d'eau je voulais cela
paraît voir nous attaquions l'opération
bourride alors 2000 d'olive des
soignants en quantité émincer gros oui
delahaye est toujours une tête d'ail
entières parce que tu là il ya beaucoup
plus de parfums comme ça un petit peu de
temps ce qui est l'emblème de la
province un petit peu de fenouil qui est
nécessaire pour parfumer le poisson un
petit peu de sel du poivre
et alors j'étais autre tension sur le
feu très vif quelques pommes de terre
car la paume de teodosic les pommes de
terre
oui parce que les pommes de terre en
donnant l'onctuosité à la bouillabaisse
à la bri et à la bourride travers la
brousse parce que je n'en prends
beaucoup fait
oui parce que la fécule aux parents
logique beaucoup plus onctueux alors
quelques mots l'os ou de livres environ
et boursière en théorie parce que
l'amour rend son jus dans le bouillant
elles ont maintenant les têtes de
poissons pour faire le font très bien
nous y sommes assez nous mettons du
petit poisson parce que nous en avons en
quantité mais enfin pour spectateurs ils
vont beaucoup mieux il vaut beaucoup
mieux que vous leur donnez ses recettes
alors fait partie tout à fait à peu près
vie j'ai fait deux matches qu'on a
jamais dans la bride
c'est ce qui la différencie opposé par
delà
et revoilà maintenant collaborer vivre
que les oignons et l'ail en tes couleurs
j'ajoute monopole de l'eau bouillante de
l'eau bouillante toujours bouillante
combien de personnes une fois personne
ne sait quoi personne maintenant que
tout en ébullition tout est en
ébullition je mets mon poisson de on
n'est pas censé les poissons entiers
alors vous mettez toujours à bon droit
si vous avez dû condenser c'est aussi
bon et à partir du moment où le poisson
commence à bouillir combien faut-il
vicomté de cuisson environ un quart
d'heure vingt minutes suivant la couleur
de vos concurrents et vous ne mettez pas
te prend alors la jamais les enfants de
safran et physiquement réservé à buyo
verse très bien alors vous ajoutez l'eau
pour bien courir votre poisson et
voulait cibler notre marque en vain
pendant que ça bout maintenant je vais
préparer maruyama d'abris alors nous
vous suivons dans la cuisine provençale
pendant que le poisson va cuire son
petit carter alors c'est aïoli profond
et bien qu il être et ben voilà on
commence par piles et d'abandonner ou de
delahaye voyez je vais marier dans mon
pilote le plus bien je 32 genève comme
exactement comme si le plus de
millionnaires et en provence l'aïoli ce
n'est pas seulement une mayonnaise à
l'ail à marguerittes ce peuple a compris
ça oui et caprices à la main des olives
et on montre la mayonnaise et vous
montez votre you lie pas mais lyonnais
grégory alors pendant que vous allez
monter sa taille au fond je crois que il
n'est pas inutile pour que nos
téléspectatrices qui ont pris des notes
tout à l'heure vérifier qu'elles n'ont
rien oublié que nous reprenions par le
détail les deux premières opérations que
vous avez réalisé tout à l'heure d'un
coeur si je me trompe vous m'arrêtez
bougies alors dans une grande marmite à
ce vif vous avez fait revenir dans de
l'huile d'olive 200 grammes d'oignon
grossièrement émincez les cochonneries
qui nous entoure et demi kilo tant que
ça bon vu quelques gousses d'ail juste
une tête d'ail entières ne donnait plus
chez écrasé dans la main ça c'est
important
oui quelques brins de fenouil à un brin
de talent une proche de bercy salle 100
g de pommes de terre coupées en
rondelles il est important de les mettre
à ce moment là pour que la fécule de nos
bouillon une bonne cure aux hits et ses
128 exemple et les têtes et les que des
poissons le tout saler poivrer
c'est exact mais sitôt que loignon et
les têtes ont pris une jolie couleur
vous avez couvert d'eau bouillante une
louche par personne environ et des plans
semblent a commencé à bouillir vous avez
jeté les 500 grammes de moules et les
poissons entiers et le tout est en ce
moment de cuire à feu très vif succès
oui c'est très important
alors cette aïoli ce terrible permettra
tout à leur écartement poisson sera cuit
de retirer le poisson de la marmite de
passer le jus ou chinois riz chinois est
un tamis pointu de mettre mon nez et
d'un jeune homme en 8es de délayer ce
jeu avec le jus que j'ai obtenus par sa
nous allons revoir et dites moi à propos
de la bourride la bourride est ce
vraiment un plat spécifiquement
provençal mais vous savez le bruit d'une
issue
sur les vols internes et l'aîné avait
exactement les sétois ont adopté petit à
petit tous les provençaunautes adopté
voilà
mais je te plats typiquement provençal
vous êtes vous-même le marché 100 %
assez rare par les temps qui courent je
laisse ce soin au cadre dans lequel vous
travaillez sept petites mains j'adore la
provence aux séries c'est une région
merveilleuse mais voilà il faut que le
plein d autres chevry c'est parfait et
la banque est ce que vous allez nous
faire la rouille
c'est à dire mais additionné du primat
du sa forme pour rendre les unit
beaucoup plus forte parce que des gens
qui aiment l'aïoli beaucoup plus forte
alors je pense du piment fort tant que
ça nacos un joli phobique c'est qu'une
différence entre les rouilles un petit
bout de sa forme et vous distrayez
combien de cuillé rebollo vous savez
trop d'accord vous pour la 306 efira des
cabris alors seraient nos couleurs une
couleur très rouge appelée la couleur de
sa fin voilà on va en laisser cette date
au rouge indique se donne là un peu de
poids et voilà la rouille et fait
maintenant je vais passer des croûtons à
l'ail pas seulement écouter ensuite
voilà voilà voilà merci vous prenez
votre travail et vous passez surtout
content des deux côtés l'opération étant
terminée nous allons à la cuisine
voici leurs abris et voilà
voilà le poisson riz cuit j'espère à
point alors je vais sortir mon coin sont
maintenant
ça donne une fin un peu de patience je
vous ai dégusté il n'est pas trop
démarre mais comme on dit à marseille et
avery 1,5 une vraie fille qui ne se
sentent pas voilà il est encore bien
entier c'est une chance il a juste
glissé qu'il fallait les tranches de
baudroie tout est cuit à point
c'était une surprise aux qu'on confond
de devoir faire c'est aïoli et cette
rouille
on n'aurait jamais dû perdre et bien
pour moi la bourride eux c'était du
poisson blanc boudy aromatisés bien sûr
mais je ne savais pas que ça se relever
par de l'aïoli et par là de chaque
région a ses spécialités
moi je mangeais l'aïoli toujours avec
des légumes et de la morue le vendredi
faut très bien le fin gras mourut aussi
mais on n'a pas la même saveur
la bri avec l'ats à la morue oui vous
pouvez servir le faire somme toute on
peut faire la bourride avec n'importe
quel droit ils sont blancs comme vous
l'avez dit au début de la préparation du
choc qu'ils ignorent c'est quoi ça va se
rejouer
ça c'est la vôtre la bourride dans un
leader c'est la mienne la bourride
fouilles vont évidemment elle est très
riche
exactement et elle va être très
savoureux bon alors maintenant que tout
ça est sorti nous allons tracer à l'abri
de la voilà vous mettez une cuillère
d'aïoli par personne dans une casserole
de casseroles à côté je voudrais bien
moi
5 et 6
alors vous prenez votre chinois et vous
sortez votre jus il faut il faut bien le
passé parce qu'il ya toujours les têtes
de poissons qui ne sont pas bien fondu
les morceaux dernier morceau de niort
les manchots de teint de rose rire de
fenouil
il ya le feu sous la casserole leur
mange le long métrage je lui maintenant
j'écrase bien le jus qui reste pour
qu'elle soit crémeux
alors maintenant voyez vous faites
exactement comme si on fait une crème
pâtissière avril voudriez votre you lie
avec votre jus et alors vous faites un
peu très doux pour ne pas que l'on
trouvera boury de ce bouchon minima
séries alors voudriez bien et quand vous
voyez que votre jeu est haché une cure
votre bruit des prêtres c'est une
secrète une très grande et les gars
c'est sur quoi elle retrouve à salon
volant
nous allons verser dans une soupière et
ensuite pour la version sur des couteaux
loyer à table selon les tables seulement
au comptant le pen se feront alors ne
laissez cuire cette semaine quelques
minutes
je veux pouvoir chez les cuites et bien
joli
et bien c'est tout voilà maintenant que
vous êtes
nous allons passer à faire un pas sur la
table je peux vous aider
pardon comme ça vous apporter le poisson
voilà quel régal
[Musique]